students in more than a hundred
countries took to the streets Friday
demanding action on climate change an
estimated 150,000 students and adults
took part in school walk outs organized
mainly through social media and word of
mouth Kenneth Craig is here with more on
Friday's global action Kenneth good
morning well good morning to you anthony
students skip school across the world to
voice their concerns about a warming
planet that they believe could be
inhospitable by the time they reach
adulthood they protested in all corners
of the world in europe more than 150
thousand gathered from Paris to Rome and
Berlin in Australia tens of thousands
took to the streets in Sydney kids
gathered in India and across the United
States from New York to st. Paul and San
Francisco we are the next generation and
we deserve to have a livable future the
movement began last year with gratitude
a 16 year old from Sweden tun Berg
gained attention with weekly protests
outside the Swedish parliament and by
taking her message to world leaders at
the United Nations Climate Change
Conference known as cop 24 you are not
mature enough to tell it like it is even
that burden you leave to us children
tunberg told crowds in Stockholm Friday
the world faces an existential crisis a
day earlier she spoke to CBS n I just
know that nothing is happening and not
no one is doing anything to fight
climate change and if no one does
anything then I would have to do
something as
spread youth around the world rally
Teresa like 13 year old Alexandria
Villasenor the youth climate strike us
co-founder has been skipping school to
protest outside the United Nations every
Friday for the past three months her
message to politicians we will continue
striking until the necessary actions are
taken we will not be stopping one
tangible change students demanded is for
countries to become carbon neutral as
soon as possible for her efforts Greta
tun Berg this week was nominated for the
Nobel Peace Prize like she took to
pretty of the city powerful but here a
16 year old tell adults were not mature
enough to tell it like it is exactly and
even more amazing to think about she
started all of this she started thinking
about climate change and she was just 8
years old wow we seen anything like this
ever it's really incredible probably
more than a million people they're
estimating protested yeah we saw some a
lot of the parkland students obviously
responding to that but this on the
worldwide scale is mobilized in the same
way yeah thank you